如果你吧，
你儿子今年出门，
学校里边儿，
你同学给他两颗牙打掉了，
你什么心情？
你看到那个女同学你什么心情？
可是你儿子还喜欢他，
你儿子还想跟他做同桌，
你儿子还不想跟他分班，
你儿子还不怪他，
你什么心情？
我今年是30岁，
我和我先生是结婚有六年，
现在有一个孩子是三岁多一点，
我们两个人的感情呢，
还是比较好的，
因为我老公他属于那种比较上进的，
非常有责任心，
他整个人除了我觉得有点小心眼以外，
整个人是很好的一个人做动伴侣，
做爸爸呀，
各方面我觉得还是挺OK的，
他是个体，
我是体制内的，
他父母是那种非常朴实且非常努力的为他们兄弟两个营造很好家庭的那种父母，
所以在他们眼中就是吃了一辈子苦的这种人，
当然和我的父母相比较，
我觉得刚开始是非常佩服他们的，
我也觉得他们非常善良，
很朴素，
所以我觉得各方面都综合考虑一下，
我选择和他结婚，
现在的问题就是这种长期的家庭环境的不同，
但我和我老公之间产生很大的矛盾啊，
刚才说的他非常有责任心，
他这个责任心其实也是他的一个缺点，
因为他是老大嘛，
可能对家里的各个方面考虑的都非常的面面俱到，
所以我们经常吵架的一个原因就在于他的观念当中是所有人都好才对，
好，
咱们三个叫小家庭。
一下好了之后大家才能好，
所以在这个过程我会很累，
带孩子上班，
基本上80%的孩子都是我自己在带，
他父母是没有这个时间帮我带了，
长期的这种压力导致我自己整个人很消极，
现在一遇到问题了，
因为这几年我父母和我老公就他们三个人的关系不是很流畅，
总感觉这点没扭了，
他觉得我父母不是特别的疼他，
我父母觉得他有点斤斤计较了，
因为我们不在一块儿生活，
所以我觉得大家能不见面就不见面，
我也没有把那个看的太重，
今年呢，
过年就发生了一件事情，
也是有这方面的原因导致了我对我先生造成很大的伤害嘛，
我很冲动就把他的牙齿给搞掉了两颗，
你干什么了，
你这么虎啊，
你笑说太歹毒了，
你我承认，
我也事后来到他家，
和他父母都道歉了，
你是用什么铁锤子啊，
扳手啊，
还是什么，
就是这一类的，
但是我不是说对着他的牙去砸的，
我是是朝他扔着，
前提是他骂我，
我也骂了他，
是他先骂了我，
我骂不过他，
我就想先去打他嘛，
因为我肯定也打不过他，
他就是抱着我的手，
掐着我的脖子，
后来我就恼了嘛，
就发生了这种结果，
当时就带着我的孩子回到父母那里，
我父母不知道是我的原因导致这个这个过程，
还有我姐姐，
我姐姐说话可能更冲一。
对他父母说的比较难听的话，
他父母就非常的伤心，
后来我爸我妈知道之后，
当天就去医院陪同，
后来我老公一直给我发信息，
劝我回家，
我们一起面对，
因为发生这个事情，
我也想好好解决，
但是我和他不一样，
我非常感性，
我不会解决，
我想事情是有因有果的，
我对他造成这样一个伤害，
大家可能都只看到这个结果，
我也承认这是我的不对，
我老公就非常的理性的说，
要我回来，
我们一起也得去解决，
现在呢，
我已经回来了，
在这一周多的时间之内，
如果抛开我们双方家庭，
我们三个人的小家，
我陪他去看，
去医院，
去走，
各种的过程，
我们都是关系还是非趁的，
但是一提到这个父母吧，
自己有心结就走不开，
导致他母亲那一开始对我说的比较难听的话，
我站在他母亲的角度我也是能理解的，
但是现在就感觉很别扭，
我一直陷在自己的这个谜团当中，
我觉得这不是一天两天形床的，
因为我本身没有带孩子就上班，
我的情绪就很难被顾及到，
孩子现在已经3岁多了，
一一来就冲动了，
现在我不知道怎么处理我们这个大家庭的关系，
我觉得这个事情真的挺严重的，
如果说他下死手打你，
你拿东西招顾他，
我觉得这个你干得漂亮，
但是他没有，
你俩只是吵架，
他没有先动手打你。
给把人家两颗牙打掉的话，
这是一辈子的，
站在我的角度，
可能我父母也有点气吧，
但是毕竟是我造成这么大的伤害，
所以我父母后来演了就什么东西来看我老公，
但是因为那天早上我们还没有起床，
我爸就可能感觉有点不好意思嘛，
他就把东西放在那儿，
他就去上班了，
但是我妈一直在客厅等着我们起来，
后来我老公就说就感觉不到清醒嘛，
现在人家对方是啥态度啊，
我老公就觉得我们只要好好的过，
我们往前看就行了，
我们该怎么回，
同学该怎么处理，
这个就好怎么处理，
就是说他还想接着过，
我老公是说你想要离的话，
那就去你，
那你要是不想回来嘛，
给我娘家，
他回来我们就要好好过，
我就感觉我肯定得婚外，
我只是做错了方式，
现在我们最大的矛盾就是我发是母们相处，
他也不太想和我父母相处，
比如说前天我们一起去玩儿，
下楼的时候碰到他母亲，
我就很尴尬嘛，
我就往门那里走，
他可能后来就说你怎么不和我妈妈打招呼，
所以说我需要一个时间吧，
现在大家把这种别的他同学的儿子就把这种问题放在明面上，
他就会觉得很难去处理，
他还想接着过你这头呢，
实话实说啊，
这个问题发展到今天，
他是一个长期积累的过程，
一句话说到头了就是你忘了你自己当初为啥找他了。
你当初找他的时候，
你图的是他的责任心，
图的是他的上进心，
你才忽略了他的家庭，
忽略了他是一个个体户，
你是一个体制内，
忽略了他的父母和你的父母可能经济条件上有一定的差距，
那你图的是人家的责任心，
图的是人家的上进心，
图的是这个，
那好，
人家有责任心，
有上进心，
人家全家都有责任心，
全家都有上进心，
全家都在奔好日子，
全家都在劳动，
全家都在挣钱，
你又忘了你当初为啥找他了，
全家没有一个拖后腿的，
全家没有一个吃了啊，
没有一个乱七八糟的，
全家都在努力挣钱工作。
你又忘了你当初为啥找他了，
但是感觉很难。
我姐妹说我们单独过，
我也想过这个问题，
包括我和我老公也是过，
我也不是你妈的仇人，
你妈妈也不是我的仇人，
而我妈也不是你的错，
就大家都是一门心思，
如果我们能单独出来过的话，
我觉得我们应该会过得很好呢。
小孩说实话，
这三年都有我在带，
我的工作时间是比较自由的，
带小孩这个事儿啊，
釜底抽薪的一个转变，
因为我经历过这个阶段，
就我老觉得我对孩子的付出可能是我对象对孩子的付出的3倍5倍，
我心里也会有这种看他不顺眼，
他怎么不能像我一样的陪伴孩子，
孩子饿了是我，
渴了是我，
拉了是我，
困了是我，
什么都是我威。
也经历过这个阶段，
两口子日子快过不下去了，
那个阶段，
但是转念就在一瞬间，
转念的一瞬间是什么呢？
我之所以对我孩子这样，
是因为这是我心目中的自己，
我之所以愿意陪伴孩子，
是因为我陪伴孩子的时候我很幸福，
我心里洋溢的满满的都是知足，
是快乐，
是幸福。
他愿意付出多少，
是他的课题，
他和孩子之间的缘分，
是他和孩子之间的课题，
爷爷奶奶愿意付出多少，
是爷爷奶奶的因果，
是爷爷奶奶和孩子之间的情感流动，
孩子爸爸愿意付出多少，
是孩子爸爸和孩子的因果，
就是孩子他从谁身上得到的力量、
温暖、
耐心，
他就对谁会多一些信任。
真的转念在一瞬之间，
自从那一瞬之间我转念想明白了之后，
我们就没有因为带孩子这件事情再去吵过架什么的，
我对象他不愿意陪，
那我就陪着孩子去游泳，
陪着孩子去各个什么公园啊，
陪着孩子去各个游乐场啊，
因为我陪孩子我高兴，
我快乐，
你不要把孩子成长这件事情当成是KPI，
当成是爷爷奶奶要完成多少，
爸爸要完成多少，
我完成了多少，
外公外婆完成了多少，
不要这样去对比，
转念就是一瞬间。
张菲姐就我们家还有一个这样的情况，
我刚才说他父母是做生意的嘛，
他家是开餐馆了，
所以这个过程也是需要我老公呢。
参与的，
因为人手不够，
当然了，
我公婆他们也是给了我老公金钱上的一个，
就相当于是平等的嘛，
就为我和我老公有时候也是，
比如说我下班回家，
我带着孩子吃了饭之后，
刚好两三点钟，
他从店里回来了，
他也想休息，
我也想休息，
他可能只有2个小时，
他又要去店里了，
我也会觉得没有人帮助我，
他会觉得他累，
他也想休息，
可能长期吧，
因为之些琐碎的事情，
其实真的在一起相处的时间，
说心里话的时候几乎是没有了，
有没晚上睡觉就是这么多时间，
嗯，
如果说因为孩子一直是你一个人管吃喝拉撒的啊，
确实人容易一郁，
容易崩溃，
其实你还是要花点钱，
哪怕减钟点工，
帮忙看看孩子，
你自己能休息，
能睡个好觉，
能做个头发，
能有点自己的空间打游戏的人都明白这个过程，
100%的血你上去了，
哒哒哒哒哒也剩到20%，
10%，
5%的时候，
你得想爸妈给自己充血才行，
你知道吗？
这事儿必须花钱，
如果说你爸妈有时间的话，
就你爸妈来带一带孩子，
让你自己去充血，
充满了血了之后再来爱孩子，
如果你爸妈没又这个时间的话，
公公婆婆又挣钱，
老公又挣钱，
他们在经济上又帮衬，
在钱上也没有亏待你老公好，
就花你老公的钱去请人来干这个事儿，
你自己去充血，
他必须要形成这么一个良性的循环。
还太小，
对，
我知道，
比如说我们家拖地这个事情，
因为我是在生孩子之前就腰间盘突出特别厉害，
就非常疼，
在去年的时候犯了一次特别严重不能自理了，
我就说拖地，
因为我是一个可能生活中有强迫症的人嘛，
就比较爱干净，
吃了饭我们就给我刷碗的这种，
我就是说要买一个好一点的扫地的机器人啊，
我老公就觉得没有必要，
或者你直接买就得了吗？
但是我会觉得这是我们两个人的家庭，
我想和他商量我们再买，
但到现在这个机器人都没有买到，
你今天现在挂了电话立刻马上买，
我就会觉得这个家不是我自己的，
我就会和自己较真儿，
我不知道这是我的原因还是怎么回事儿，
我要什么事情都像一个分配任务的，
一个长官，
你要干50%，
我干50%，
不是的，
日子不是这么过的，
日子就是我想要什么我得到，
我想要什么我实现，
我甭管是拿我的钱实现了，
还是说我从我老公的口袋里面掏点钱实现了，
反正我想要什么我实现。
日子不是说像一个分配任务一样的，
你干50%，
我干50%，
你陪孩子三个小时，
我陪孩子三个小时，
这次孩子生病了你去，
下次孩子生病了我去，
这次孩子家长会你去，
下孩子家长会我去，
日子不是这么过的，
这次是我想要什么我得大，
我想要什么我干，
我想要什么，
不弄明白了，
我以后不可能这样吧，
现在我反人面对他父母吧，
孩子反觉很尴尬，
我问你吧，
你儿子在学校里面被。
同学打掉了两颗牙，
请问你看到你儿子那个同学你是什么心情，
你就理解他父母看到你是什么心情了，
你要允许当父母的人看到你，
觉得你欺负我儿子了，
很正常啊，
客客气气的相处呗，
我就问你吧，
你儿子今天出门，
学校里边儿女同学给他两颗牙打掉了，
你什么心情？
你看到那个女同学你生么心情？
可是你儿子还喜欢他，
你儿子还想跟他做同桌，
你儿子还不想跟他分班，
你儿子还不怪他，
你生么心情？
我能是接他吗？
理解不就完了吗？
就客气气的相处嘛，
对不对？
我觉得我们现在能搬出去就好，
但是这个代价嘛，
就头大了，
就可能还没有办法做到这种我们三个搬出去单住的这种时间可能慢慢的就淡化了，
因为他父母也是很朴素的那种人，
我觉得大家都没有错，
就是错的，
就是我这个方式我也认错了，
我也跟他们家，
包括跟我老公我们三个，
我们也说了好多，
现在我们就想好好的把日子过下去，
我感觉为什么这家只有我自己一个人呢？
大孩子什么都是给我，
我老公就说我不理解，
他说我的好多选择都是不成熟的，
不理智的，
我再问个问题啊，
就你们家一年消费多少钱，
大概就10个，
这10万块钱主要是谁贡献的，
我的工资也是全部都就没有了，
每个月嘛，
还有我老公的钱，
你挣的多，
还是你老公挣的多，
哈，
挣钱也是贡献呀，
是不是就像刚才姐妹们说的，
请个育儿嫂啊什么的，
我们当。
自己想了嘛，
几个月的时候就是没有想到合适的，
再加上我的工作又比较的灵活，
所以可能这个事情主要就是我带了嘛，
我又并没有说为了孩子拿孩子去说事，
只是说在这个过程当中，
我的情绪必须要自然理解的，
如果可以的话，
挂了电话了之后呢，
第一自己下单买个扫地机器人，
第二呢，
你还是需要去医院看一下，
我没有恶意啊，
我是觉得你长期陷入一种惯性思维，
你长期的惯性思维就是觉得你付出的更多，
你的牺牲更多，
就觉得你更不值得，
你没有跳出这个框框来看，
跳出这个框框来看，
你的老公，
你的公公，
你的婆婆，
他们都在努力的笨生活，
他们都不是坏人，
他们都是善良的人，
他们都没有干什么缺德事儿，
他们都没有欺负你，
都没有针对你，
只是我们在一个家庭当中，
我们的角色不同，
分工不同，
可能是孩子更依赖你，
把孩子你带着，
这就是普通人的生活，
这我知道，
我这么说，
有很多姐妹说，
龙飞姐，
你是不是不太理解我们这种带孩子的人啊？
我早就跟你说过了，
想要带孩子的话，
要么是钱能帮衬，
要么是人能帮衬，
生孩子之前就得想好到底谁能帮衬你，
而不是说自己一个人24小时看孩子，
谁24小时看着孩子，
谁都得疯，
谁都得抑郁，
你现在这个情况就有点儿，
我感觉是，
我也不敢想，
所以我就说提个醒，
你可以去看一看，
去医院去看一看，
我就感觉自己很拧巴，
因为你已经。
进入一个死胡同了，
你只看到了自己的付出，
只看到了自己的付爽，
只看到了自己，
但你没有看到。
其实整个画面来说的话，
人家公公婆婆在挣钱，
人家没毛病啊，
你老公也在挣钱，
人家没有一个人是坏人，
没有一个人欺负你，
没有一个人说我给你耍心眼子啊，
没有啊，
那全家人都在过好日子啊，
好吧，
好，
非常想问题的时候不这么纠结啊，
那就这样啊，
拜拜，
我现在的心理状态是什么啊？
日子过到现在，
对别人的要求都非常的低，
我对自己要求也低了，
现在我对人的要求越来越低，
只要他大体上是一个正常人，
大体上是一个善良的人，
大体上是一个没有乱七八糟的干那些缺德事的人就很好了。
因为一旦你对别人要求低，
对自己要求也低的时候，
你活得非常自由，
活得非常知足，
活得非常好，
记得点赞关注哦。